bonjour à tous alors nouvelle vidéo sur
b3 au premier coup et cette vidéo à
faire office de récapitulatif alors on
avait déjà fait une avec une partie de
nîmes dovic est là donc ça sera la
seconde est sans lien direct avec donc
deux articles que j'ai écrit sur le site
de check point com est donc aujourd'hui
on va prendre la partie de fisher contre
le fondeur san donc il ya le pgm dans
l'article mais là en plus donc on
expliquer un peu plus voilà en vidéo
donc c'est un peu différent dans la
partie et au passage je vais expliquer
de trois autres choses pour que vous y
retrouviez bien dans les variantes alors
b3 on l'a dit l'idée des blancs s'est
fait refouler 2 et donc de contrôler le
centre à distance mais donc les noirs
peuvent l'occuper soit par des cinq soit
par cinq
donc ce qu'on avait vu dans le premier
article est dans la vidéo de l'année à
la fois avec nîmes dovic c'était ce plan
là avec ses 5
donc bien sûr il ya d'autres courbes c5
et on avait vu donc en général les
blancs jouent avec 3 et foot b5
par exemple cette position là et là j'ai
juste en profiter pour montrer
rapidement une partie que fisher a lui
même joué avec les blancs donc c'était
contre making making le grand maître
brésilien donc tu as un bon joueur d'en
bas là c'est la partie jouant 1970 mais
c'est un joueur dont que bien qu'ils
avaient joué trois des candidats et/ou
ensuite fou 17
donc on rappelle un les noirs veulent
pas se laisser doubler les pions et donc
les blancs bon jeu pour le contrôle de
la case de s'inquiéter le cavalier voilà
donc je vous montre rapidement à la
partie de fischer s'est passé là vous le
montrer et puis on a déjà fait une vidéo
là dessus mais ça fait office un peu de
de révision va dire est bon qu'on avait
dit le fou bien sur cette diagonale on
peut ce travers la troisième rangée pour
passer la tour et donc fischer c'est ce
qui fait tenir amène ses piètres droit
là une jolie menace ça serait
potentiellement dame pranger cette
attention s'ils n'en font pas attention
qui joue disons à 4 on peut y aller
direct franco avec le dame prend g7 fou
prend tout reprend échec le roi van asch
8 et on va commencer à faire des
découvertes et a tout mangé par pour
mange là on mange encore la dame ensuite
et on aurait donc une pièce et de
tourner plus voilà bon alors évidemment
making a vu tout ça il avait fait flux
prend le 5 comprend le 5 et f5 mais là
il ya un truc sympa je pars par fischer
s'est prise tout reprend aidé à me
ranger cette très jolie
en fait comme ça sur dame prend on peut
reprendre un f6 et on aura un pion de
plus c'est une finale qu'il a ensuite
gagné g4 pas mal qu'ils avaient à liège
3 donc pour venir sur la case de 5 et
donc g4 pas mal pourquoi parce que
maintenant on à jessains qui vient
soutenir la tour est comme ça est bien
placé pour la zone un peu le roi noir et
sur cinq qui avait acheté une partie qui
avait encore durer une petite vingtaine
de coups et fisher donc s'était imposé
donc ça c'était juste pour faire ma
vision est donc ce qui nous intéresse
maintenant c'est le coût 1,5 donc que 5
pareil pour jouer des 5 et prendre le
contrôle du centre donc on n'a pas ce
que font les blancs c'est fou les deux
attaques le pion et noir défendre par
kelly c6 alors une autre option pour
défendre ce serait faire des six mais je
vais en parler un peu plus tard en gros
là dessus il ya deux manières de jouer
pour les blancs de plans possibles c'est
soit de jeu avec des quatre pour essayer
d'échanger ception des contreurs est
donc redonné beaucoup de vias to b deux
sur une bonne diagonale première option
la deuxième option c'est de partir du
principe que les noirs donc ont mis
leurs pions comme ça pour bloquer sous
b2 mais que cette diagonale là serait
intéressante et donc de jouer avec un
double fond de kétou donc joué que j'ai
trois mètres le fond j'ai deux mes
documents ses quatre plus un schéma
d'anglais ce qui est intéressant
également nous on va y revenir un peu un
petit peu dessus un tout petit peu après
donc qu'est c6 et voilà donc là dans la
partie fischer a fait ses 4 et comme je
l'expliqué dans l'article
deux approches possibles donc c'est soit
on fait ces quatre comme fischart pour
pâtes ou les réduire en d5 sert des
quais à venir on va les changer par une
pollution de 6,6 à l'inversé en quelque
sorte son on laisse faire les noirs mais
il faut absolument attaquer le centre
faut pas jouer des coups anodins donc
que trois cesser complètement dans
l'idée comme ça sur des 5 on peut jouer
avec fougue et 5
donc on cloue le cavalier et on attaque
le pion donc les normes ne défendent
avec food et 6 sûr qu'on continue
l'attaqué f4 et donc l'idée bien sûr
c'est que scipion prend ce serait très
grave il ya vous prend g7 et on enferme
la tour et on est gagnant avec les
blancs les noirs cherche à défendre
leurs pions et peut y avoir des
tactiques et en tout cas on joue pour
faire pression sur le centre j'ai mis
deux parties dans l'article une de
arancibia et une de richard rapporte
vous invite à venir la regarder c'est
plutôt bien analyser et et voilà donc ça
c'est si les noirs veulent construire
gros centres ont la tâche et ce qui peut
faire aussi c'est comme d'habitude donc
jouer avec des six dont je les lis ton
fessée 4g trois fous g2 et ses oncles et
venir aux deux petits rock et peut-être
quand même des quatre plus tard soit
sinon on peut jouer donc d4 direct mais
on s'expose éventuellement à ce que les
noirs puis ce cercle comprend en plus on
prend et des 5
donc je vois un peu qu'on se fout b2 qui
ne les prennent pas génial ici même si
ça reste possible de jouer comme ça il
ya une partie pendant que andrei sokolov
avait gagné dans le match ol 2014 contre
kevin rose art vous pourrez la trouver
dans par votre base l'autre manière
jouer c'est de préparer des 4 par
exemple ont fait cavaliers 3 cavalli
vient f6 est maintenant fait des coups
et l'a donc en cas de prise
on va évidemment reprend avec une pièce
donc le cavaly qui était venu là pour ça
donc pour faire je le fous mais deux sur
sur la bonne diagonale c'est pas mal
après les noirs ont aussi l'option de
jouer une position plus ferme et et on
va avoir une sorte de
deux françaises inversée quelque part
voilà donc le fou pas génial en b2 mais
on croit toujours
éventuellement à l'échangé à a3 et puis
on est donc ce cahier sinon ces trois
prendre ici et faire pression sur le
centre mais ça c'est plus typique donc
d'une française inversée voilà donc
plein de choix possible c'était juste
pour dire un mot sur sur cette option
donc avec le 3 et enfin non pour finir
ce que je dois dire c'est que la la
ligne principale actuellement c'est
plutôt celle ci donc avec food et 6 a
une nouvelle fois indécis serait
possible mais je pense que donc
maintenant une fois qu'on a sorti le fou
là on a plus le plancher trois fuseaux
évidemment donc on va plutôt jouer avec
cavani eux deux et d4 ensuite vorsino
val fourré de vannes et donc voilà ça
c'est la ligne classique food et 6 donc
qui défend le pion même si le fou est
pas hyper bien placé pour l'instant que
sylvain ferme le fossé 8
c'est le genre d'idées qu'on peut voir
quelquefois se fout des six notamment
une des lignes de dans la 4 cavaliers
par exemple autres b3 premier coup sûr
celle là le 4 5 cavaliers f3 cavalli ces
six cavaliers ces trois cavalières six
fours b5 et le couffo des six est quand
même jeu par des joueurs de d'un bon
niveau c'est pas idiot donc l'idée du
fou les 620 4 cavaliers ou donc ici
nantes avec g3 avec des trois cantons
qui nous intéresse donc c'est de
défendre le pion et que le fou soit que
de manière passagère pour repartir
normalement les fuites plus tard une
fois qu'on aura rauque et le tour huit
pour faire des cinq à bon escient
deuxième idée possible avec fodé cissé
que si on joue avec eux quatre ils
éventuellement le fou pour revenir aux
cinq contester le fourbe et de parme
s'est changée ou glisser le cavalière de
5 serait pas mal voilà mais le plan
typique des normes ce trade rauque et la
tour ce train est fuite
à ce moment là la place t128 maintenant
que la case est libre on rangerait le
fou et on jouerait des 5 tout en
défendant ce pion pour être avec les
blancs faut aller assez vite pour
contrer ce plan et c'est pourquoi ici en
général les blancs joue cavalier à trois
guides et donc c'est de venir en c4
taper sur le foot abaissant le pion de 5
donc les noirs en généralement et vittek
est relié à 5 ce qui serait aussi
possible pour jouer ces assisses prendre
et reprendre 2d et se dire oui sur quel
essai 4 je peux défendre avec dams est
donc ce qui est vrai mais les blancs
peuvent jouer en quel lieu de rock
ensuite et f4 pareil pour encore faire
cet espion et que le fou je joue bien
sur cette longue diagonale
il ya eu quelques parties comme ça et
bon bah ma foi c'est quand même pas mal
pour pour les blancs quoi c'est
intéressant comme plan voilà donc payer
ces deux cas ya trois cas y a cinq sinon
ça c'est très possible
bon bah ce qu'il faut faire danser
retirer le fougueux 2 alors pourquoi
parce que maintenant il a fait son job
en bessin qu'il a plus rien y faire il
va secteur il va être exposé à des
tempos soit ces six voire à 6 le fou
pour partir et des 5
donc on s'en va on se libère la caisse
b5 pour le cavalier et recommencé à
attaquer le fou qui pourra pas fuir
parce que y aura le pion aux cintres
donc normalement les noirs ont évité et
là on fait ces quatre alors important
pour plusieurs raisons déjà pour prendre
le contrôle du centre 2,2 sur damas est
le cavalier à trois pas trop de cases
une fois qu'on aura laissé 4d il pourra
revenir en c2 et pourra aider donc à
jouer des quatre voire aussi peut-être
b4 et enfermé ce cavalier la verra 5
voilà donc là je peux vous dire de
retourner voir une vidéo sur blick
stream c'était la ronde deux des
olympiades partie de christian bauer
donc gelé aussi cité dans l'article et
si on avait essayé de bien analyser
c'est kevin bien expliqué donc voilà je
vous conseille de retourner voir cette
vidéo là maintenant la partie de fisher
donc c'est l'autre option on a dit où il
faisait ses 4 et donc il prend contre le
d5 donc veiller sur ses marges des 5
comprend donc rozehnal c'est une
position de 6,6 à l'inversé comme on va
vite le voir là il a fait dames c'est
dans la partie je vous montre l'autre
fait déjouer détroit mesdames ces deux
très bien à 65 ou utiles on le verra
mais la pme et d'être ensuite un donc
donc ça change pas grand chose
et donc voilà cette fameuse pression de
2,6 y ait un adversaire qui a et b les
deux donc le cas libyen place et on ne
savait pas venir en c4 ravi de la
pression sur aux 5 ou en 4 et
éventuellement versés 58 donc il ya le
choix c'est pas mal et dernière chose
aussi qui fait bien en d2 par rapport à
ces trois et qu'il obstrue pas le flou
b2 qui t'a bien qu'absente epci ce petit
rock faut aussi ce est donc cette partie
avait été très marquante
pas tant par le fait que fisher jouber 3
mai par le plan qui vend plus maintenant
absolument très profond et bien joué
serwa ch dont ses débuts du plan bon je
vais venir sa taille pas de mine à
première vue d'amener cette tour g1 est
là donc on comprend mieux en fait il
veut faire g4g 4 puis j'ai cinq donc la
tour g1 très bien placés en face du roi
adverse et de deux deuxième idée donc de
jouer comme ça avec g4 g5
c'est pour pouvoir faire taper le fou
sur cette diagonale donc avec le cas
l'hiver au 5 et puis aussi vers m6 et
pourquoi pas sur g7 donc c'est très bien
pour ramener nos pièces nokia s'en sort
des 8 il a joué cavalier ou 4 donc place
ce cavalier direction de ces cinq
évidemment être 5 servirait pas du tout
enfin servir à rien ça le nouvel par son
maquillage et 5 donc on est de prendre
le fou et puis aussi bien sûr ceux qui
on est beaucoup moins bien protégé donc
babel 7
l'eba g4 c'est parti avec les normes
fondées reçues à jouer g6 donc évident a
évidemment y voit un peu l'idée blanche
kg 5
il se dit bon je fais j'ai 6 7 5 comme
ça je bloque parce qu'une personne est
plongée 5 on pourrait aussi être tenté
de confier par g5 un g6
donc voilà dont j'ai 3 prépare à doubler
les tours c'est chose faite
k&b 6 donc il l'a retiré ça fait une
attaque sur b3 mais avec ace et 5 ont
fait une pierre trois coups d'effets en
b3 attaque six attaques bessette les
marcheurs partaient ensuite avec le fou
il ajoute qu'ils allaient h 4 maintenant
bas il continue en fait son attaque à la
hache 4 ça va inclure l'idée de pouvoir
venir à 25 avec le cavaliere parce que
si on prend plus on prend on voit en
fait les deux tours doublé bas juste
attaque le four g7 donc ça posera un
problème au noir deuxième chose qu'on
peut faire avec le cannage 4 s'est
libéré le pion f pour potentiellement
faire f4 plus tard si j'aimais ça nous
intéresse à la réunion fait cai et 17
pour essayer d'échanger lecavalier
fischer a refusé c'est normal parce que
les pièces noires sont un peu les unes
sur les autres
donc quand c'est comme ça on en refuse
refusé changer les pièces quand on a
plus d'espacé donc donc normal le
cavalier noir donc il l'a retiré vérifie
tout voici venir colmater un peu tout ça
et le fameux bouquet f5 dont je vous
parlais arrive donc le cavaly est tabou
parce que donc scipion préemption
prendre en attaque deux fois le fou g7
il n'y a pas de manière de défendre
par exemple s'ils font rage suite est
bon on y va pour prendre dans le prendre
pour prend ra prend hélas on peut dire
pour me qualifier 3 on peut repasser le
cas l'hiver h5 le roi noir est assez
faible
je rappelle quand on a un rapport aux
matelles dames font du matériel donc là
ces dames compte deux tours bon c'est
une dame qui ont toutes deux tours même
en vo faut avoir l'initiative pour le
camp qui à la dame mais on voit que
l'âme peu serein et facilement aller le
roi que ce soit par ses quatre g4 ou h4
et elle arrive
est ce être dangereux points noirs en
plus on peut faire suivre par f4 on
parlait tout à l'heure ça va ramener le
four version 2006 donc ouais ça ça
serait juste normal ont perdu facilement
enfin gagnant facilement pour les blancs
l'autre coup ce serait fou prend un f5
puis on prend et j'ai 50 ans bon je
tente de fermer mais ça ne marche pas
parce qu'il ya quelques lampions et une
nouvelle fois on va te couvrir les deux
tours doublé fonds grosse pression sur
la colonne j'ai donc il est escaliers en
cinq entrées sont préfère ne pas le
prendre on le laisse là où view aussi
s'y rattachent le pion b3 baffie
champêtre à notre alliance et 5
il fait son job ici on l'avait retirée
juste parce qu'il n'aurait fait que 17
pour les changer maintenant que la
partie on peut venir ans et ça alors il
a fait qui a lieu cette alors
potentiellement c'était possible de
sauver ce fou de faire pousser 8 mais de
toute façon les blancs allaient prendre
un jet set et avec un nul très bonne
position pour le croit prend on peut y
aller en fait h 4 et on va pouvoir
rester le roi et on est mis avec les
blancs simplement des mots bonne
initiative on à la paire de fou c'est
plus plaisant à jouer
mais donc vraiment sympa ce plan de roy
h un pourtour qu'il ya un an j'ai un
puits g4 c'était une des premières fois
qu'on l'avait vu ce plan peut-être la
première fois je ne sais pas et ça a été
employée depuis alors des fois que tu es
noir contre les étonnements roxy il ya
après
des partis là-dessus je me souviens
j'avais lu un chapitre dans le monde
élites de droite ce qui quand j'étais
petit mais c'était vrai c'est vraiment
un plan qui sort de l'ordinaire est
assez profond et puissant quoi ok alors
qu'avait lieu cette jouer qu'à
l'étranger cette croix pranger 7 et
enfin g5
donc on était là depuis un moment par
l'est ont créé la rupture sur ce plan
maintenant tu as honte quand même pu
être 5 parce qu'il y aura le pion de
cinquantenaire donc là les noirs
commencent à être pris de toutes parts
cavaliers f5 bon ben on retire la tour
et on commence à créer un clouage sur le
cavaliere b6 attaque lequel ces cinq ils
apprécient ces intermédiaires rouages
suit alors le problème sur dame france
et qui aurait juste cavaliers 4 la dame
doit partir et ce pion la saute au
prochain coup cette photo de cinq échecs
et en plus on pourrait pour super kf 6
ou 7 6 en finale
donc ça va pas du tout ouais j'ai pris
froid suite mais l'envoie en fait que la
pression des noirs est déjà perdante
et là un autre bon coup perd ses
centrales des quatre qui sera d'ailleurs
utilisé dans la partie de fisher contre
tout mac os
vous pouvez retrouver dans l'article et
qu'est ce que ça fait beaucoup des cas
donc c'est une pression au centre
toujours bien quand on a la paire de fou
de voir le jeu deuxièmement ça délivre
ce show 2 qui peut venir en c4 faire une
enfilade sur la dame et la tour puis on
prend des 4 eh ben la fameuse enfilade
arrive détroit bon bah ils encaissent le
pion ni pour voir à la fois menacé de
revenir en ces cas pas fini ou de venir
prendre ici toi prends des trois indices
de qualité mais c'est plutôt désespérée
les noirs voilà voilà il ya plus grand
chose à dire je vous fais défiler des
derniers coups de manière assez rapide
d'ailleurs fisher ne relâche pas la
pression et continuent de s'en prendre
au roi adverse
il ramène ses pièces à fond et l'abandon
va bientôt arriver
ici abandon donc vraiment une très belle
partie de la partie fischer je peux vous
remettre la partie en plein pendant que
je fais ma petite conclusion up web est
donc très belle partie plans hyper
intéressant ça peut donner des idées
donc pour d'autres pour vos propre parti
et donc voilà donc je vous invite à
aller lire l'article
celui là est donc le premier ce n'est
pas encore lu la prend à partie ça vous
fait un petit résumé un peu donc sur
tout ce qui peut se passer sur ce coup
b3 premier coup alors c'est pas 100%
complet mais je pense vous pouvez de
prêts déjà pour le tenter en pratique et
voir un peu et ce qui compte aussi c'est
voir un peu donc surtout là prêts à
partie de l'article la méthodologie que
je proposais pour ce faire un père
thouaré choisir une variante à base de
partis classiques voir un peu comment
les choses ont évolué avec le temps mais
les plans restent pour bien comprendre
la position les tenants et les
aboutissants tout ça voilà bah écoutez
l'histoire ça vous a plu
si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à mettre
un petit pouce bleus et à vous abonner à
la chaîne et puis donc pas je vous dis à
bientôt on va s'auto sur les parties des
joueurs français donc voilà allez ciao
ciao